hi I'm hustle minhaj and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
how do we swap out some of the Google
images of me like my Wikipedia photos
pretty horrifying it's like me like
okay people on Google are asking what
did Hassan minhaj study I was a poli SCI
major in a film minor which isn't even a
thing you could pretty much Wikipedia
what I studied a film Miner is like
three YouTube videos I'm sorry UC Davis
what did Husson minhaj say about Ellen
DeGeneres I didn't say anything Google
don't get me in trouble I just had uh
Ellen pronounce my name properly and
that my Starbucks name is Timothy
chalamet I guess apparently that was a
huge internet thing are you getting a
higher percentage of more accurate
pronunciation since then actually the
more people try it's actually getting
worse it's that kind of like uh that
well-intentioned Progressive liberal
thing where people are like Hassan
do you know what I mean like the way
when you're in Spanish class and you
were like and you're like relax and you
say you can just call me Timothy
chalamet from here on out what did
Hassan minhaj get on the SAT
people on Google are savages I got a
1310 on the SAT unfortunately and I
really tried I took the Princeton Review
twice and still got a 1310 so that was
me maxing out fully turned on Adderall
this engine has a 1310 in them and then
I retook it funny enough for Patriot Act
the score that I got as an adult man in
my mid-30s was in 1100. so the score
that I got now wouldn't even get me into
the school that I went to as a Young Man
very humbling what is Hassan minhaj
favorite food I think there's different
categories favorite food at home
favorite food at a restaurant favorite
late night food which bucket shall I
answer I had a signature sandwich called
the Menage à trois in my 20s where I was
really struggling as a comic coming up
and it consists of wheat bread Chipotle
mayo which I thought was like a
revelation in my life chicken breast and
or turkey a toaster oven and pepper jack
cheese the internet lambasted me when
they saw me put it together with avocado
and saw that I could not cut avocado
properly people were making a real
hullabaloo out of it
next board
[Music]
how Husson minhaj how did Hassan minhaj
get famous I'm sentencing a lot of
passive aggressive energy with these
questions because I asked stuff like
this because I'm a hater too I'll go to
Google and be like is Adam Driver
attractive I think like my cousins in
Delhi are like how did this happen how
did how soon get popular
and then people in the YouTube comments
will be like I have no idea who this
person is you may know me from The Daily
Show with Jon Stewart I was one of the
last correspondents hired by John or
maybe you know me from the White House
correspondence dinner or homecoming King
my first Netflix special or my show
Patriot Act one of those things that I
probably ended up in your timeline or
news feed in some capacity how tall is
Hassan 6-1 with hair and I take a lot of
pride in that it was height important
too girls on dating apps girls will be
like I want someone sensitive smart
intelligent are you diet well-read
cultured 510 or over please am I am I
lying I'm not like I'm just I've seen
this this is like very ruthless so I'm a
big beneficiary of that I asked my wife
being at this like what do you like most
about me I'll have multiple detailed
answers about my life I'll be like
you're sophisticated yet sexy you're
smart well-spoken sweet you're so great
to my parents but then you have this
amazing soft spot for like our children
and she's just like you're tall for an
Indian guy how old is House of manhosh I
just turned 37 and boy oh boy am I
feeling it stretching and hydration
that's my life now
how to dress like hustle minhaj see
that's sweet it's medium that's the
secret I describe my style it's kind of
like Americana swag kinda just so you
know internet a lot of the stuff that I
wear is borrowed so it is returned
immediately
when Hassan minhaj when is Hassan minhaj
coming back right now on YouTube on
wired's official YouTube channel I think
this is in regards to when I'm coming
back to Netflix that's October 4th the
king's gesture on Netflix streaming now
talking about fertility fatherhood
stories about marriage you know
homecoming King I had just gotten
married I hadn't had my own show yet I
hadn't been sued by a hedge fund for
telling jokes what was the outcome of
that it's uh dismissed as I say in the
special we never heard from those
[ __ ] ever again hi Randall Smith
when was Hudson minhaj on The Daily Show
I was on The Daily Show from 2014 to
2018 and there were some of the best
years of my life so a particular segment
I was most proud of I think the first
interview that I did with prime minister
Justin Trudeau is pretty awesome to walk
into the prime minister's office in a
full Canadian tuxedo and not have anyone
bat an eye or say anything about it was
the most Canadian thing ever when did
Hassan minhaj get married January 2nd
2015. I will say this and I'm pretty
proud about it I remembered our
anniversary and my wife forgot and I've
flexed so hard thank you Google Calendar
when did Hudson minhaj start comedy I
started comedy as a freshman in college
one of my roommates at UC Davis was
illegally downloading TV shows and
movies I wasn't because stealing is
wrong he illegally downloaded Chris
Rock's Never Scared which was his
special in 2004. I was like holy [ __ ]
this is amazing I gotta do this some of
my earliest jokes were really really bad
I think one of my first jokes was like
the premise was hey isn't it weird when
you're living at home with your parents
and like a girl you like calls the house
and then your dad picks up the phone
landline humor kind of dated
is Hassan minhaj
a doctor
no I'm not basically my dad and my mom
opened up Google every day and they're
like why isn't Minaj a doctor I think
that's what you need to add is why isn't
ashamed doctor question mark no I'm not
a doctor but I did I do make jokes about
the medical community because I know
them intimately well as a person who
started as pre-med and then became a
poli SCI major I know their pain and
their anguish and regret is Hudson
minhaj related to Nicki Minaj No I did
briefly meet her at the Met Gala and I
was like hey we should take a picture
together and Trevor knows like hey yeah
you should he's like he's like your
brother and she was like what and she
walked away so we never took the photo
but you know
stuff like this happens with family
members is Hassan minhaj in the morning
show yes I'm in the Morning Show season
two I play Eric namani who is a new
anchor who comes to the morning show and
shakes things up is Hassan minhaj funny
these questions are very trolley yeah I
think I'm funny I would hope I'm funny I
feel like my wife wrote this like is he
is he really funny
last card Hassan minhaj
Riddler oh this is great yeah I uh I am
playing Riddler in the new Spotify
series Batman unburied the great Winston
Duke plays Batman it is created by one
of the greatest I think comic book and
film adaptation director writers of all
time Mr David goyer who's absolutely
brilliant I was like oh David's calling
me to be Batman and he's like nah you're
more of a riddler Hassan minhaj skin
care I use my wife's SkinCeuticals so we
have like uh his and her sink and mine
has this like a Gillette Mach 3 and just
like a half used bar of soap and then
hers has like an Erlenmeyer flask a
titration set
oh cool uh Hindi means what will people
think and in my first Netflix special
homecoming King I talk about how so many
dreams die
because of local there are so many
roomies that became electrical engineers
because of what will people think it's
truly tragic as they say in homecoming
King [ __ ] Loki I can't get Hassan minhaj
Timothy chalamet that's my Starbucks
name and by the way
You misspelled his name there's an
accent over here get it right oh they'll
be like Timothy and I'll be like it's
timoteo oh man y'all are in the comments
and heated look I do a joke about MD's
versus Dio's in my new special Kings
Jester a lot of doctors of osteopathic
medicine I'm pronouncing that correctly
got upset about the joke and what I want
you to know is I love Dio's you guys are
good doctors I want to say something
that your parents never told you I'm
proud of you and I don't care about your
MCAT score why do you
thank you wired appreciate you guys
until next time I'm hustle manage take
care guys
[Music]